Xin cảm ơn các bạn đến với khoa học
thích sẽ miễn phí từ cơ bản đến nâng cao
dành cho người mới bắt đầu được thực
hiện trên kênh YouTube là Excel bài số
21 công thức mạng trước khi bắt đầu vào
bài học số 2 một mình cùng giải bài tập
số hai mươi hôm trước nhé các bạn sẽ mở
cái câu hỏi của bài số 20 hôm trước lên
ok Đây là cái dữ liệu Nga yêu cầu là gì
ạ Ở đây mình sẽ vẽ hai cái biểu đồ phần
trăm theo các nhà phân phối của từng sản
phẩm và phần trăm theo các cái khu vực
của từng sản phẩm đấy mình sẽ vẽ hai cái
biểu đồ này nhá thì bây giờ các bạn sẽ
vào cái cùng dữ liệu này để vẽ 2 biểu đồ
này các bạn làm như sau nhé các bạn sẽ
vào cái thẻ nên sợ này các bạn tạo cái
file table Để bạn xem bấm ok thì đây là
cái vùng dữ liệu web nhé đấy Ở kia là
yêu cầu cho sản phẩm của bạn có thể kéo
cái sản phẩm vào cạo râu đấy và các bạn
sẽ kéo doanh thu vào cái ba lưu này sang
đây Các bạn thấy lại đây là yêu
số Viettel cả nhà phân phối mà yêu cầu
theo khu vực đúng đấy thì đầu tiên mình
sẽ làm nhà phân phối trước nhá thì có
kéo cái nhà phân phối vào cái cửa sổ
khác lầm ở đây đấy Sau đó các bạn sẽ vào
cái thẻ Lara Các bạn chọn vay vốn chào
lại mình sẽ chọn cái biểu đồ này nhá Đây
là tính biểu đồ thể hiện cái phần sang
đây này các bạn xem ok lại thì như vậy
mình đã được cái biểu đồ kia rồi các bạn
thì các bạn có thể nhấn chuột phải là
các bạn chọn 2 ôn Đấy cái phần nhà phân
phối vận kéo lên đây Nhá cái này các bạn
thích người này thôi sẽ con dặm đã lại
cái nhà phân phối thì em còn kéo rộng ra
đây lại các bạn sẽ thích vào cái cục địa
cô sản phẩm lên này các bạn sẽ ấn căn
trước một nhá đầy sau đó mình sẽ ko nhỏ
cái ra người lạ nhìn nó đẹp hơn đúng
không đấy thì ok như vậy mình đã xong
những điều này rồi nhé Bây giờ mình sẽ
làm thêm cho cái phần ở khu vực đúng ạ
Đấy thì cách đơn giản thì các bạn sẽ Bôi
đen Cái vùng vai hút này các bạn thích
một đây sau đó gọi Nhật phải các bạn
Coffee để gọn rất xuống đây các bạn sẽ
bấm HTV luôn đấy thì nó sẽ tạo một cái
vie3t bù mới luôn lại và lúc này mình sẽ
thay cả các bạn sẽ kéo nhà phân phối ra
và mình sẽ kéo cái khu vực đó đây Đấy Và
Các bạn hãy chọn để các bạn vào like Các
bạn chọn vibook sạc đấy các bạn sẽ chọn
cái đồ ngay nhá OK thì xin nhái được bày
với lại các bạn sẽ phải ôm đi Cái này
còn sẽ thích vào đây này cả mặc áo rộng
ra
xe tải văng cái iTune này mình rất cả
lên trên nhé á
anh giải cảm giải thích ở đây mình sẽ ko
cái này xuống đây là khu vực Bắc quanh
kéo lên đây à
Ừ ok thích thu nhỏ nó này lại cho gọn dễ
hiểu nhé à
ừ ừ
có ai gọi thể tích vào đây các bạn nhảy
điệu phải các bạn chọn format there are
three mình sẽ con cái này
Ông cho rằng cái khuôn lại các bạn thấy
cái nào đẹp thì bạn làm nhé Vậy ok như
vậy Mình vẫn xong cái câu hỏi của bài
thứ 20 nhá Bây giờ mình sẽ đóng lại mình
sẽ vào bài học ngày hôm nay là công thức
mạng nhé các bạn sẽ mở bài hay mốt lên
nhá mình sẽ bỏ cái bài 21 lên à
thì các bạn sẽ tích ở enable editing các
bạn chú ý mình sẽ đẻ cái link tải file
thực hành trong phần mô tả phía dưới
video tốt nhất là các bạn tải về các bạn
vừa theo dõi và thực hành cùng mình nhé
mình cũng bắt đầu vào bài học ngày hôm
nay thì trong Bài học này Hôm nay mình
sẽ hướng dẫn các bạn người ví dụ về công
thức mạnh từ cơ bản đến nâng cao đầu
tiên mình cần hiểu công thức mạng là gì
công thức mạng trong Excel là công thức
mà chứa tham chiếu tới các mạng hay cụ
thể hơn công thức mạng sẽ xử lý nhiều
giá trị thay vì một giá trị như công
thức vì sao thông thưởng ở đây giả sử
mình có ví dụ thực hiện sản phẩm này số
lượng đơn giá bây giờ mình cần tính tổng
tiền không ạ Nếu nhưng mà công thức
thông thường thì các bạn sẽ bằng thì các
bạn sang lấy số lượng các bạn nhân với
cả địa nhân với cả đơn giá đấy còn sẽ
enter thì đây là cái công thức thông
thường nhá họ sẽ bước vào đây đấy thì
sau đó Ở đây các bạn sẽ rửa các bạn sẽ
bằng xong này xong của Tổng ở đây đúng
không ạ rồi còn em tơ thì như vậy tổng
tiền đấy là 8.000
ở trạm thì đây là công thức Excel thông
thường đúng ạ Còn với công thức mạng mẹ
thì có thể liên lạc với nhau đấy Ở đây
có bạn sẽ thì các bạn sẽ bằng này các
bạn sẽ bằng xong này các bạn tắt nhá thì
các bạn sẽ lấy là gì thay vì từng giá
trị nên với nhau thì bạn tham chiếu là
gì Các bạn lấy mạng này tức là diện từ
Nivea đến 17 quá nhân với cả diện nhân
với cả đơn giá là gì từ C3 đến C7 rồi
còn sẽ đóng ngoặc đơn lặng thì đây là
cái công thức mà tức là gì công thức là
tham chiếu tới mạng không ạ bình thường
chỉ là một ô nhiễm với nhau cái đó nhưng
mà mình Đây là việc một mảnh nên với
nhau mạnh đây là gì từ Nivea đến với
bệnh nhân với cả rẻ Liên lạc từ C3 đến
c70 ạ Ngoài ra để thực hiện công thức
mạng ấy thì sau khi các bạn Nhập công
thức đi thì các bạn phải giữ phím
Control Z rồi các bạn ấn enter nhá Đấy
thì như vậy đây là công thức mảng nó sẽ
ra rìa 8198 còn đấy chứ Đấy đúng như Kết
quả đây là 8198 được đấy thì như vậy Các
bạn thấy cho mình nhá công thức mảng để
thực hiện được thì các bạn phải giữ cho
ship
ở ngoài ra thì công thức mạng và sau khi
các bạn ấn cái chương sĩ enter họ sẽ
thấy cái công thức mảng nó có cái mỏ
nhọn và đóng ngoặc nhọn ở trước và cuối
cái công thức nhá đấy thì để hiểu với
công thức này thì các bạn làm như sau
nhé các bạn sẽ thích và Kyo kết quả này
các bạn xem vào cái thẻ Fortuner các bạn
sẽ chọn cái gì average phong lưu này đấy
thì sau đó các bạn sẽ tích và cái
average nhá thì nó sẽ giải thích các bạn
các bước cụ thể để làm cái việc này nha
qua sự tích ở đây đấy thì nó là gì ạ Nó
sẽ nhân với cả điện từ Nivea như C3 đấy
thì nó sẽ ra là gì 2478 Bạn ấy chứ Thì
cái giá trị đầu tiên là gì 2478 sau đó
lại thực hiện là viện nó lấy B4 nhân với
C4 thì nó lại ra là gì ạ 590 đấy bạn thế
mà nó cứ tuần tự như vậy nhá và đến các
bước cuối cùng là gì đi mày như phê bẩn
thì nó sẽ ra làm gì 20074 và tổng của 5
cái giá trị này lại với nhau thì nó sẽ
ra là địa 8198 này Đấy gọn đấy chứ Kết
quả là
U18 các bạn sẽ bấm close thì như vậy
công thức mạng là gì ạ thì nó khác với
công thức thường là gì công thức thường
của các bạn là chỉ lấy từng giá trị
nhiên với nhau còn công thức mảng ấy thì
nó sẽ lấy là mạnh giá trị tức là nó tham
chiếu đến mạnh nhé một vùng giá trị Ok
thì mình sẽ làm cái ví dụ 2 cho bạn hiểu
thêm nhá thì trong ví dụ 2 mình có cái
hiện ở đây mình có tất cả là bảng công
ty từ lãi sang một đến gái cho mày nhá
Đây là doanh thu của năm 2019 đây là
doanh thu của năm 2020 bây giờ mình cần
tính xem là công ty có tăng trưởng cao
nhất và thấp nhất là bao nhiêu đấy thì
vẫy Xe Thông thường thì các bạn hay làm
như sao Con sẽ bằng Vì ạ Các bạn lấy năm
2020 gọn - diễn năm trước là năm 2019
Các bạn bấm enter đấy Sau đó các bạn lên
đây Bạn thích bút nhé và các bạn sẽ dùng
cái hàm mắt và min đúng ạ Nếu bạn để
tính cẩm cao nhất của bạn sẽ bằng thì
các bạn sẽ bằng mắt các bạn tương tác
nhé bác một cái vùng giá trị mà tăng
trưởng đây này các bạn enter đấy thì nó
sẽ ra 76 đúng không và min thì họ
anh bằng nhiên các loại tem nhé pin của
cái vùng giá trị này thì nó sẽ ra là nó
sẽ ra là 42 thì thay vì mình sẽ dùng
nhiều cái công thức như này thì mình sẽ
dùng công thức mạng nhá để họ sẽ bằng gì
ạ Các bạn để tính cái giá trị cao nhất
thì bạn vẫn là dùng hàng hóa đúng ạ Xin
mở ngoặc đơn gian và Rịa các bạn vững
lấy cái mảnh ở đây từng là cái năm 2020
từ C2 đến C8 à các bạn - - năm 2019 là
thứ bê hai đến ba tháng sau đó bạn đó
hoặc đơn này lại và các bạn thì nhớ cho
mình là các bạn giữ control ship và các
bạn ấn enter nhá Đấy còn thấy chứ nó ra
76 giống như Kết quả đây rồi đúng ạ thì
tương tự với Hàm Nghi thì bạn cũng làm
như vậy thôi các bạn bằng Min các bạn
tắt nhé nhưng của mở ngoặc Bạn lấy năm
2020 - năm 2019 Ở đây các bạn thứ nhát
mình phải lấy mạng - mạnh cái là một
vùng giá trị các bạn trừ cho nhau các
bạn đó hoặc đơn ạ Các bạn giữ tiền ship
và bấm enter đấy thì như vậy giá trị
thấp nhất là 142 đó giống như Kết quả
đây rồi
Ừ ok Giả sử mình sẽ thay cái 100 này
bằng bằng 30 đi các bạn enter thì như
vậy Lúc này giá trị thấp nhất lại là 6
và giá trị lớn nhất lại là 63 lấy bạn
thấy chứ rất là hai ạ Ok mình sang ví dụ
thứ ba là gì ạ Giả sử mình có một cái
vùng giá trị đây nhá Đây là cái vùng dữ
liệu của mình nhá thì nó là dị nó khóc
có các cô giá trị này có các cô lỗi đây
là màu trắng công nghiệp gì cả Đây là
cái ô ô công thức hoặc bằng miệng bằng
màu ghép giống hoa kép luôn Và đây là
cái ô mà đít không đấy thì mình sẽ có ba
cái câu hỏi của cái ví dụ thứ ba này đầu
tiên là gì mình đến số ôm lỗi này tức là
gì ở đây sẽ có bao bị lỗi nó này là một
con này là hay và online ngã ba thì mình
sẽ xem là bao nhiêu bị lỗi không ạ thịt
để xác định được một ô bị lỗi anh không
thì con sẽ bằng các bạn sẽ bằng cái hà
Miss Euro đấy có ấn mũi tên xuống nhá và
các bạn ứng đáp thì các bạn sẽ thích bảo
với ô mà mình kiểm tra xem là Oh này nó
bị lỗi không các bạn enter đây nếu nhưng
mà không bị lỗi thì nó
anh lấy kết quả là không ạ Tại vì đây là
nó hỏi là có lỗi không thì không mà có
bạn sẽ kéo không đây Thì như vậy là
Thiện những ngôi làng bị lỗi thì nó sẽ
trả về chung đấy bao này là bị lỗi mà
chả biết chụp thì còn chuối nhà ở đây
mình đã nói về chi tiết các cái lỗi
trong Excel được cái hà Miss Euro này nó
sẽ bao gồm các lỗi lần diện ở đây nó có
bảy cái Lỗi cơ bản thì ở trong bài này
mình chỉ ví dụ cho các bạn 3 cái lỗi
trong cái tập các lỗi của cái hàng alo
thôi nhá Đấy thì như vậy Ở đây mình sẽ
dùng cái công thức mạng nhá Đấy có sẽ
bằng với ạ Các bạn sẽ bằng cái hàm xong
luôn đi các bạn sẽ bằng xong các bạn
đánh tát nhá xanh của diện cái hà Miss
Euro có ở nguy trên xuống và các bạn tư
pháp thì công thức mạng là địa có bạn
rất tham chiếu luôn đến toàn bộ vùng dữ
liệu này để thay vì như vừa xong là mình
chỉ tham chiếu đến một ô đúng không ạ
Các bạn xem đóng ngoặc đơn này ạ Để như
vậy mình đã xong cái hàng alo còn sẽ
đóng ngoặc đơn lại để mới xong cái hàng
xong Nếu như các bạn giữ cần cho ship mà
bấm enter thì nó sẽ ra kết quả lỗi đấy
bạn với dành cho xíu vậy enter đi đấy
Bạn thấy nhất là nó bằng 0 là lỗi
mà tại sao lại như vậy à còn tính đưa
vào đây tại vì cái hàng y Alo này nó sẽ
trả về chua và phô bây giờ mình phải
chuyển với Trum và khô lại về Cái kiểu
giá trị uống ạ thì sau cái hàng Alo này
Đấy tức là cái đóng ngoặc Để xong cái Hà
miz alo Có ảnh nhân một còn giữ ship +
Ân những một đấy Sau đó các bạn hãy giữ
cần ship và bấm enter nhá Đấy bạn thấy
chưa thì như vậy Kết quả nó sẽ bằng 3
đấy Mình phải chuyển cái giá trị Chu phu
này việc 011 đấy bằng cách là mình nhân
những một các bạn Facebook vào đây đi
ngoài cái cách như một đi các bạn sẽ xóa
như một đi nhé thì một số bạn rồi các
bạn sẽ thêm hai cái gạch ngang ở trước
cái hàm y Alo này thì nó cũng chuyển về
dạng số đó các bạn giữ quyền trên sheet
lại enter thì nó cũng trả về kết quả là
ba nhá thì hai cái cách này hoàn toàn
giống nhau thôi đấy các bạn có thể thêm
gì thêm hai cái gạch ngang trước cái Hà
miz alo này hoặc là gì ạ sau cái hàng y
Alo các bạn nhân như một là được nhá Đấy
Ok sang ví dụ tiếp theo là gì mình sẽ
đến cái chỗ chỗ
anh ở đây mày xóa cái tuần này đi đến
chỗ trống thì con chuối ngự ở đây nó chỉ
có một ô trống là overlay này thôi đúng
ạ tại vì cái ô này nó làm bằng công thức
làm ở kẹp đó hoặc Ghét luôn thì nó vẫn
hiểu là dạng không phải là ô trống đúng
không Thì để xác định nếu chống lại
không các bạn sẽ dùng cái hàm isblank
nha các bạn bằng iblank để gọi đến tác
và các bạn thích vào cái ô mà các bạn
cần kiểm tra đúng không còn nó bằng đơn
này Các enter nó bằng phone là điện là
ông rỗng các bạn kéo xuống đấy thì như
vậy Ở đây là Chu thì có mỗi một ô trống
thôi đúng không cái hành này bằng mở
ngoặc kép đổ có ghét gì nó hiểu không
phải là ô trống nhé để bạn Xóa đi bây
giờ để dùng cũng thức mạng các bạn sẽ
bằng các bạn cũng dùng những cái vừa
xong hơn xong thì các bạn thay cái Hà
miz Euro bằng điện bằng y Play để gọi
được áp và dịu lúc này mình tham chiếu
không phải là một ô nữa mà một cách mạng
ở đây là tự ô D3 đến B9 các bạn đóng
ngoặc đơn lại để xong cái hàm isblank
đúng không ạ nhân viết một để chuyển về
dạng số để đoạn
khi đóng ngoặc đơn lại để xong làm xong
và các bạn giữ tiền ship và bấm enter
nhé đấy thì như vậy chỗ trống ở đây là
một bây giờ ví dụ mình xóa hay bày đi
các bạn 4minute đi đấy Bạn thấy số chống
nó bằng hai mình sẽ lưu lại nhé chết là
gì ạ Nó sẽ yêu cầu mình kiểm tra cái số
ô không phải là trống Đúng không các bạn
khác với anh thì bạn chú nhá các bạn vẫn
là gì à các bạn sẽ bằng cái hàm y blank
đúng không ạ tấn pháp này và cái ôm này
gọi m Bây giờ con sẽ kéo xuống đây thì
bây giờ những cái khuôn này mình phải
chuyển về xu nó vào các bạn sẽ tích lũy
về đây mình sẽ thêm với hàng lót nữa Tức
là mình sẽ phủ định nó đúng không Nó các
bạn xác và cao enter đấy thì như vậy là
gì ạ Nó sẽ chuyển về chú hết con sẽ mua
vào đây đấy thì mỗi cái này nó chuyển vô
thôi đúng không đợi thì như vậy Ở đây
mình sẽ bằng gì Các bạn sẽ bằng xong
tham của mở ngoặc các anh tát nhá xăng
của mở ngoặc các bạn phải trên cái hàng
ngót để các bạn mở ngoặc ra của cái hàm
gì isblank các loại Yến
It is Black của cái vùng dữ liệu này gái
gọi Sơn đóng ngoặc đơn lại để song ca is
blank các loại sân đóng ngoặc đơn lại
xong cái hàng lót đúng không và các bạn
Nhân Mỹ một để chuyển nó về dạng số đúng
không ạ và các bạn nó bác đơn lại để
xong ra làm xong và các bạn giữ tiền
ship và bấm enter cho mình nhá Đấy thì
như vậy số ô mà mẹ không trống ở đây là
6 rất là hay luôn Ví dụ cái blog này
mình đánh số một rồi đấy nhá thì bọn đấy
chứ số ô gì Ô không chống lại đây là lúc
này Tháng 7 Và chỗ trống ở đây là bằng
không đấy mẹ lưu lại nhé ví dụ cái U23
này mình chuyển thành lỗi đi Ví dụ mình
diện mình sẽ bằng 1 chia đó không thì
lỗi này là lỗi ít không có bạn enter này
thì lúc này sẽ đổ lỗi nó sẽ tăng lên là
thành bốn đấy Ok sang ví dụ thứ tư là gì
ạ Ở đây nhá mình có là gì Giả sử mình có
nhiệm vụ là 5 nhiệm vụ đấy mình có số
ngày hoàn thành và đây là cái phần trăm
tiến độ thì bây giờ nói yêu cầu là diện
dùng cái công thức mạng để tính là phần
số tổng của cái dự án này đấy thì thông
thường để tính cổng hoàn thành của dự án
này các bạn làm như sau các bạn sẽ bằng
các bạn xem lấy cái ngày ở đây này các
bạn nhân với cả Thiện Nhân với cả phần
trăm hoàn thành ở đây gọi enter thì nó
sẽ ra được số ngày đã thực hiện đúng
không Con sẽ kéo xuống đây đấy Sau đó
thì các bạn sẽ tính thì toàn Xứng bà này
Song Song của mở ngoặc ra các bạn lấy
cái số ngày đã thực hiện ở đây để đoạn
đóng hoặc lại còn chia cho diện chia cho
xem các bạn phát nhé Xong của xuống này
yêu cầu đây có xem đóng ngoặc lại thì
lúc này là diện nó sẽ ra 0.24 thì dựa
vào cái hôm đi họ sẽ tích phần trăm đấy
thì lúc này nó hoàn thành là gì hai mươi
phần trăm này hay 4,05 đấy thì mình sẽ
dùng với công thức lại cho các trường
hợp này nhá để họ sẽ bằng với ạ Các bạn
vẫn là xong thôi xanh của gì có bạn sẽ
lấy thì cái này ở đây này cái họ sẽ nhân
với cả gì nhân với cả cái phần trong
hoàn thành ở đây các bạn xem đóng ngoặc
đơn này để xong em xong đúng không Sao
nó còn chia cho thì chia cho xong chưa
đó xong của liệu của cái xuống này
em yêu cầu đây để qua xem đóng ngoặc đơn
lại Xong làm xong và các bạn phải giữ
cần ship và bấm enter nhé đấy còn thấy
chứ Thì lúc này nó ra kết quả 24 chúng
không Nam đấy bạn thấy con rất là hai ạ
thì các bạn thử nhé với cái trường hợp
này thì ngoài cái dùng công thức làm gì
có thể dùng cái làm xong cậu đắng nhá
Đấy thì trong cái này mình đã chỉ cho
các bạn cái hàng xong crack rồi thì các
bạn có thể tham khảo thêm xanh ví dụ thứ
năm thì ở đây mình có một cái số bắt đầu
và số Kết thúc đấy Ở đây sẽ có bốn với
yêu cầu nhỏ là diện tính tập từ cái số
bắt đầu đến kết thúc này tính trung bình
từ số bắt đầu đến kết thúc và tính số
nhỏ nhất và lớn nhất của cái bắt đầu và
kết thúc ạ Đây thì mình sẽ làm như thế
nào thì với cái nhỏ nhất và lớn nhất thì
thực ra rất là dễ rồi Các bạn có thể
bằng cái nhỏ nhất thì con sẽ tích và số
bắt đầu ở đây thôi đúng không ạ để cái
số lớn nhất thì bạn bằng với cả cái kết
thúc ở đây đấy Thì bây giờ mình sẽ tính
tổng của chúng mình như thế nào tính
tổng của chúng mình được bạn chứ nhà ở
đây mình có một cái hướng dẫn các bạn
ngừa các
cho hàm râu kết hợp với cả Index để các
bạn sẽ tính được cái chuỗi từ cái số bắt
đầu và kết thúc đấy thì còn chuối nhát
ví dụ về A2 là diện là cái bắt đầu và B2
là kết thúc thì bạn sẽ dùng cái hàm này
với bạn bè sử dụng công thức mặc đấy mà
tính tổng thì bạn dùng làm sao đúng
không để họ sẽ bằng này xong các mở
ngoặc nhá thì mình sẽ dùng cái gợi ý ở
đây thì họ sẽ bằng cái dâu này dâu của
mở ngoặc đấy xong là các bạn diện Index
các loại ấn mũi tên xuống và các cảnh
cáp nhá thì đầu tiên làm gara xưởng ở
đây là số bắt đầu là A2 đúng không lấy
đoạn và cái gì các bạn và mới cập tức là
các bạn sẽ nối thêm với chuỗi hai chấm
trước cái số bắt đầu và kết thúc ở đây
của các bạn xem mở ngoặc kép ra hai chấm
đóng ngoặc kép lại và các bạn già với rẻ
và cái kết thúc rồi đây các bạn đó đưa
lại để xong cái hàng Venus này các bạn
đóng ngoặc đơn lại là xong cách làm dâu
chú ạ Các bạn xem đóng ngoặc đơn lại để
xong cái hàm xanh đúng không các bạn giữ
tiền ship và bấm enter đấy thì lúc này
ra là địa tổng từ 2 đến đến 100 là gì
1049 bây giờ ví dụ mình từ 2 đến 4 thôi
nhé đấy thì tức là gì 2 + 3 + 4 Các bạn
thấy chứ nó sẽ bằng xin đấy ví dụ 2 đến
5 nhá thì nó ra kết quả là 14 có thấy
không rất là hai ạ Đấy mình sẽ xem cái
công thức này nó hoạt động như thế nào
nha các bạn sẽ tích ở đây các bạn vào
thẻ Ford Laser các loại phân tích một
đây để kiểm tra nó chạy từng bước một
nhá các bạn chửi nha Cái bước mà nó gạch
chân Tức là cái nước nó sẽ chạy này nó
đang gạch cái số ahh hay đấy này thì nó
sẽ thay A = Giá trị hay đây là họ sẽ
thích đấy Đấy tức là bằng hai đúng không
sau đó nó và nó cả gì cái hai chấm các
bạn thích được đây đấy thì lúc này nó dễ
gì ạ hay không là hai chấm đấy sau đó sẽ
tiếp tục là Và với cả Hyo B2 các tích
vào đây Đấy thì nó làm và năm có ít tiếp
đấy thì như vậy đó là Index của từ 2 đến
5 đúng ạ Các bạn sẽ thích một đây đấy
thì như vậy cái nourish nó sẽ chuyển cái
vùng tham chiếu 2 đến 5 về giá trị này
từ 2 đến 5 đấy à
ạ sau đó là xong thôi ạ Xong thứ hai đến
năm luôn này còn duy nhất cô dâu từ 2
đến 5 thì nó sẽ hiểu được điện sẽ tách
ra là ai Này ba này 45 để chọn sự tích
vào đây đấy bạn này chứ nó sẽ là xong
của 2 3 4 5 các bạn thích mở ra đấy nó
sẽ ra 14 các bạn lâu lại nhé chỉ ví dụ
đây mình sẽ thành 100 đi đấy còn rất
thích ở đây được kiểm tra nhé thể chọn
sơn tinh vào đây này thì cuối cùng nó là
xanh của dâu từ 2 đến 100 đấy còn đấy
chứ Xong Cô Dâu Thứ 2 đến 100 và nó gửi
xong của 2 3 4 5 6 đây là đến 100 người
con thấy không rất là hay luôn bằng 5049
cái Trung bình thì tương tự thôi mình sẽ
tay xanh vàng Everest nhá lại các bạn sẽ
bằng Everest các loại nút lên xuống và
các bạn phương pháp mình sẽ dùng cái
hàng thì có bạn sẽ lâu này Các mở ngoặc
ra Index các bạn sát này của diện các
bạn sẽ tích và cái ô A2 này các bạn và
bây giờ mở kép
a đóng ngoặc kép bạn già mới gì vào cái
cái B2 này để gọi sự đóng ngoặc đơn lại
để sống hàm index các bạn đóng ngoặc đơn
lại để xong hàm râu và các bạn đó Bắc
đơn lại xong cái hàng Everest các bạn
giữ truyền cho ship và bấm enter nhá Đấy
thì nó sẽ ra là giá trị là 5 mốt mình sẽ
vào thì hôm đi các bạn sẽ tăng thêm lại
bây giờ ví dụ mình sẽ cho là từ 1 đến
100 nhé Còn gì chứ Thì lúc này giá trị
trung bình là gì 50,50 là rất là hay
luôn Ok mình sẽ sang đây ví dụ Thứ Sáu
cái ví dụ thứ 6 là gì ở đây mình có hai
cái trường là trường rủi ro trưởng doanh
thu và trường biển đúng ạ thì rủi ro có
các mức là gì cao và thấp còi doanh thu
cũng tương tự nó sẽ có cái mức cao và
thấp và nó sẽ tương ứng ở đây là cái
điểm nhá thì ở đây mình yêu cầu là việc
biển tối đa của các trường hợp nhận rủi
ro là cao và doanh thu là thấp đúng
không Bây giờ các bạn sẽ vào đây cái rủi
ro là cao đúng không ạ Đấy Doanh thu là
diện Doanh thu là thấp đấy vào
thời tiết biển tối đa thì như vậy với ba
cái giá trị này biển tối đa là bao nhiêu
là 75 đúng không Thì mình phải trả về
kết quả là 75 đấy Còn nếu như mà yêu cầu
điểm tối thiểu thì nó phải là thì 6 năm
thì ở đây mình sẽ yêu thì ở đây mình sẽ
làm cái việc tối đa nhá khoảng các bạn
các bạn sẽ làm cái gì cái điểm tối thiểu
cho mình nhé Bây giờ mình sẽ thích còn
đây Mình bỏ Kim tôi đi bây giờ bạn sẽ
làm nhé các bạn Thủy nhé cái phần công
thức mạng thì mình sẽ không làm được và
cái ô mà mất đâu các bạn không được mới
nhé bây giờ để tính điểm tối đa đúng
không có họ sẽ phải bằng bằng cái hàng
mắt đấy tại sân mỏng hoặc đưa ra thì là
dễ mắc của cái gì Các bạn sử dụng cái Hà
mít để mình lấy điều kiện đúng không còn
sắc màu hoặc lương ra vì ở đây mình dùng
hai cái điều kiện để cho nên các bạn
phải mở ngoặc đơn nữa tại vì cái điều
kiện thì sẽ ngăn cách nhau bằng việc bạn
ghép nhân giống như cái hàm sang Gold
đây đấy thì cái biểu thức lôgic nhá thì
đầu tiên cái vùng điều kiện thứ nhất là
gì Các bạn saponin cái phần rủi ro đây
rất là rẻ từ App
A11 đúng ạ hoặc bằng điện bằng mở ngoặc
kép các bạn sẽ ghi lại bằng cam rất là
rủi ro cao lại các bạn đóng ngoặc kép
lại và các bạn đó mặc đơn lại để xong
cái điều kiện thứ nhất nhé Tức là cái
rủi ro cao không Các bạn sẽ nhân với cả
diện ngân mới cả mở ngoặc tôi sẽ bôi đen
cái nguồn doanh thu ở đây ạ là từ Diva
đến b11 mà bằng bằng Mỏ Két ra là bằng
thấp đấy ta sẽ đóng ngoặc kép này lại họ
sẽ đóng ngoặc đơn lại để xong cái cái
biểu thức Điều kiện thứ hai của cái Hà
mít này đúng ạ Bây giờ bạn sẽ phải thì
như vậy là Thiện sau khi mà thỏa mãn cả
hai điều kiện là rủi ro cao và doanh thu
thấp đúng không Thì mình sẽ trả về cái
gì đây là khi pha lê ít Chu mình sẽ trả
lời cái cục C này là cột điểm đúng không
Từ C3 đến C11 đấy các bạn xem đóng ngoặc
đơn lại để xong cái hàm ít các bạn đóng
ngoặc đơn lại để song ca mắc đúng không
ạ Và Các Bạn giữ cần ship và bấm enter
đấy thì như vậy là gì ạ Cái biển tối đa
là 75 bây giờ mình sẽ tính cái điểm tối
thiểu thì các bạn khiến tranh mà mi là
được nha các bạn sẽ thích
em sửa lại các bạn sẽ tay móc khóa mini
vì lúc nãy như bằng 62 sao nó có bạn giữ
tiền cho ship và bấm enter amin là 65 65
vào mắt là gì mắc là 75 đấy thì ấn độ
lại nó còn để làm nhé Ok sang ví dụ thứ
bảy là gì ạ Giả sử đây là cái vùng dữ
liệu của mình nhá Yêu cầu là diện nó hỏi
là có bao nhiêu số mà chứa các cái số
sau đây tức là gì ạ Đây là các cái số mà
mình cần đến làng 1257 đúng không Mình
sẽ đến toàn bộ trong cái vùng dữ liệu
này bao nhiêu số là diện là 1 2 và 5 và
7 đúng không đấy thì ở đây kết quả là 16
nhá bữa nay ví dụ là một này cạo dưới
càng trôi một này hay này cứ thấy 1257
thì bạn sẽ Bôi đen này và rõ sẽ đến tổng
là bao nhiêu đúng không Đấy tất cả nó sẽ
ra 16 bây giờ mình sẽ thử hết các bạn
cái công thức mạng nhé đấy nếu như mà
các bạn dùng cái hàm cao ít bình thường
thì nó chỉ đến một điều kiện là theo ông
này thôi đúng không nó không thể Đếm
ngược cho cái vùng điều kiện này cho nên
mình phải dùng công thức mạng đấy thì
mình sẽ làm
khoa học cao nhé để có lẫn tạp thì con
thứ nhất cái hàm cao này nó chỉ đến cái
ô mà chứa giá trị số cho nó vào ví dụ
Bôi đen toàn bộ vùng dữ liệu này đi các
bạn enter đấy thì cái hàng cao nó sẽ trả
về là 44 đúng không đấy bạn sẽ thích nó
vào đây mình sẽ sửa nhé Ở đây không phải
là cao của cái này đâu con sẽ mở ngoặc
ra đấy Cao cái gì mình sẽ dùng cái kem
ít đúng không em mình theo điều kiện mà
ít nếu như mà gì mình sẽ dùng cái Hà mát
nét để cái hành Tìm kiếm nhé mình tìm
kiếm cái gì mình tìm kiếm toàn bộ cái
vùng dữ liệu này đúng ạ Phải cái lúc up
Đây là điện lúc cấp là mình đến cái vùng
dữ liệu ở đây là từ G2 đến gần em lúc
khác phải mình tìm chính xác sẽ là không
đúng ạ Các bạn sẽ nó hoặc đơn lại đấy
thì như vậy Ở đây là diện cái hạt mát
này vừa hay gram ở đây là cái vùng dữ
liệu Tức là cái mảnh chứ không phải là
mô bình thường không đấy nếu như cả mét
này mà diện mà lớn đúng không Tức là nó
tìm thấy thì nó sẽ trả về cái cả lớn
không không đấy thì gọi cho xong cái
biểu thức lôgic nha bạn sẽ phải Nếu như
mà tìm thấy thì các bạn xem
thế này cách là mình chỉ quan tâm những
cái ông tìm thấy thôi đúng không có họ
sẽ đóng ngoặc đơn lại Để sau khi làm ít
đấy các bạn đóng ngoặc đơn lại được xong
làm cao và các bạn giữ tiền ship vào bấm
men tôi nhá Đấy còn thấy chứ nó sẽ trả
về cái khoảng 16 Bây giờ con sẽ mới đây
nhá mình vào cái file này các bạn sẽ
tính vào đây là mình kiểm tra từng bước
một nhá đầu tiên là diện nó sẽ thực hiện
cái hàng mét này nhá Đấy bạn sẽ thích ở
đây này chưa thi là diện nó đến tất cả
các vùng dữ liệu này cứ thấy bất kỳ số 1
hoặc số 2 hoặc số 5 hoặc thứ Bảy thì nó
sẽ đến mày còn thấy đầu tiên này một đây
là northern blot đây là số một cái bạn
thấy chưa 100 không phải bốn không phải
10 không phải sóng và 94 không phải đến
với số một này thì nó mới tìm thấy lại
cái số một ngày tương ứng với số 1 đến
đây đúng không tiếp theo là gì nó sẽ tìm
được cái số một này là tôi không biết số
1 Đó đây đấy tiếp theo là gì Số 2 đây số
2 đây Đấy nó cứ tìm Như Vậy Nhé lại
đi đái chọn ý tiếp vào đây này Nó sẽ trả
về là 16 đấy Ok sang ví dụ thứ tán là gì
ạ Mình ở đây mình có một cái số mình
nhập vào nhé Bây giờ là yêu cầu là việc
tính tổng các chữ số đúng không Thì
trong cái ví dụ này nó sẽ tính tổng là
năm này + 6 + 5 thì nó sẽ ra là 16 đấy
và thứ hai là địa tổng các giá trị từ M
đến n Thì cái này nó giống như một cái
ví dụ trước mình đã làm rồi đúng không
đấy Hình như là cái ví dụ thứ năm đấy
Đây là tổng từ cái đầu đến cái kết thúc
đấy thì trong cái ví dụ thứ 8 này mình
chỉ làm cái phần này nó nhé Cái này thì
nó giống như cái ví dụ tiếng năm nữa bây
giờ cái quy tắc của mình là diện mình sẽ
dùng cái Hàn mix đồ đúng không Mình sẽ
dùng cam hết đồ để mình tách từng Cái ô
này ra và kết hợp với cả cái gì cái hàm
râu vậy hàng interact đúng không cái
hành dâu và Indonesia thì nó sẽ tách
được ra thành từng các phần tử của cái
mặt đúng không và cái Hàm Nghi đồ nó sẽ
lấy một ký tự thế nào nó sẽ lấy tuần tự
từng các phần tử một cục
thì các bạn sẽ bằng đấy ạ bằng các bạn
sử dụng để làm sao đúng không xanh là
tính tổng rồi đúng ạ Các bạn sẽ dùng cái
Hàm Nghi đồ mix đồ của gì cái tách thì
vẫn là cái số này đúng không đấy thì bây
giờ cái số này mình sẽ tách ra từng cái
phần tử một đúng không còn phải này thì
cái start number là gì ạ thì cái sát
number là gì mình sẽ dùng cái hàm râu và
hàm hàm index đúng không Để bạn sẽ dùng
cái hàm râu gạo sức mở ngoặc đưa ra các
bạn sử dụng cách hành integrex gọi đến
Tab nhá Thì cái Internet là dễ tăng sẽ
mở ngoặc kép ra các bạn sẽ bắt đầu từ ký
tự đầu tiên của một này sau đó bạn hai
chấm đấy nếu như mà thông thường thì bạn
sẽ nhập số 3 vào đây thì nó sẽ là một
trong là 2 và 3 đấy thì hàm mix đồ là
diện nó sẽ lấy cái ô này và nó sẽ lấy
bắt đầu từ cái ký tự một cái thứ hai thứ
ba đúng không Thì nó sẽ tách ra thành
được từ thứ tự 1 đấy đấy Nhưng mà mình
sẽ không dùng cái số ba đây tại vì là dễ
cái số này mình sẽ nhập từ ngoài vào
đúng không sao nên chọn sẽ nó hoặc ghép
lại và có
các bạn sử dụng với Hà Lan gen của mở
ngoặc bằng diện của cái thì Cái ô này là
ba thứ tự có và sẽ đóng ngoặc đơn lại để
xong hàng Nem các bạn xem đó hoặc đường
này để xong hàm index Họ sẽ đóng ngoặc
đơn lại để xong cái hàm râu đúng không
Đấy như vậy mình nó xong cái stab nhé
nếu như ngô này có bốn số thì cái len nó
sẽ trả về bốn thì nó sẽ tách ra là diệt
1234 để cho lên cái xe grab Nó sẽ thay
đổi để mục đích của mình là riêng mình
sẽ tách một ký tự mà cho nên kết bạn
đang bờ nó sẽ dịch từng cái thứ tự một
Đúng không Lấy phải và mình sẽ lấy 1 ký
tự của cái hàng Little các bạn sẽ đóng
ngoặc lại để xong Hàm Nghi đồ đúng không
ạ Bây giờ các bạn thấy nhân một để nó
chuyển về dạng trạng số này nếu như bạn
không nên mới một nha các bạn sẽ thì các
bạn tôi đóng ngoặc đơn này để xong làm
xong đi Bạn giữ tiền ship mọi enter đấy
nó sẽ trả lời Không ai bây giờ còn Sơn
F2 thì gì ạ thì sau cái hàng mix đồ này
lại các bạn phải nhân một và các bạn bên
đó mặc đưa lại để xong cái hình xăm đúng
không để chọn giữa tình thương ship ở
nhà thơ thì lúc này nó sẽ trả về cái
khoảng 16 bây giờ mình xem với công thức
này nó hoạt động như thế nào nhé
cô còn xác định về đây thì đầu tiên là
gì nó sẽ kiểm tra cái B3 này họ rất
thích bọn em về luyết đấy thì B3 là bằng
565 bây giờ nó xét diện led của Ova thì
đầu tiên nó sẽ tính B3 trước này Đấy là
gì 565 bây giờ nó sẽ tính tiếp là cái độ
dài của 565 là ba thứ tự đúng không đấy
thì như vậy cái hàm index sẽ trả về lại
từ một đến ba này còn tích vào đây Đấy
nó sẽ trả về từ một đến ba bây giờ cái
hàm index nó sẽ chuyển về 13 số bình
thường thấy một đến ba thì cái hàm râu
này nó sẽ chuyển về thành 12 mà ba cho
nên các ký tự bắt đầu của cái hàng mix
đồ này nó sẽ dịch từ thứ tự một đúng
không lại bạn thấy chứ nó sẽ là 1 2 và 3
thì đầu tiên là một thì nó sẽ lấy năm
này đến 2 thì nó sẽ lấy Sáu và đến ba là
nó sẽ đến năm đấy nó sẽ lấy tách được từ
khí tự một đấy đoạn này chứ sẽ tách từng
ý một là năm sáu và năm đấy Bây giờ mình
sẽ phải nhân ngồi Tại vì đây là cái tách
này chọn chủ nhân nó là tách thì cảm thể
chuyển về số bằng cách cả bạn nhân với
một đấy
ở đây nó sẽ ra là 565 khác xem chi tiết
này nó sẽ ra cái khoảng 16 bây giờ ví dụ
mình thích là điện 12341234 lấy kết quả
là xem bằng 10 đấu 11 + 2 + 3 + 4 chia
bằng mười là rất là hai ví dụ 23456789
Cẩm từng ngày nó sẽ ra đi 44 đã rất là
hay luôn Ok xanh thấy dự thứ 9 là gì đây
là cái tên nhá thì con thứ nhất tên thì
nó sẽ cùng nhau đó bằng ví dụ gái xe này
có gái xe này Thóc thì có 10 sao gạ thì
có một em ở đây lại có hai đấy thì yêu
cầu của mình là dễ mình phải lọc được
cái danh sách duy nhất đấy thì mình làm
như thế nào thì các Thúy Nga trong các
ví dụ thứ 9 mình đã làm các bạn rồi
nhưng bây giờ mình sẽ giải thích luôn
cho các bạn nhé bởi vì cái này nó cũng
khá là phức tạp thì các bạn sẽ về nhà
quá tìm hiểu thêm nhé mình sẽ giải thích
từ cái phần rơm này đi cho các bạn dễ
hiểu này Tại sao lại Giải thích từ phần
rơm nhá Tại vì từ cái lớp này nó mới có
trùng nhau đúng không sau kem đây này
sau bốn cái phần tử này là chưa
ý đến các phần tử thứ năm là gái Seo
trùng nhau thì nó không lấy đúng không
đến kem trùng nhau thì nó cũng không lấy
vào nó sẽ lấy đến cái rương này cho nên
mình sẽ tích vào đây được mình giải
thích cho các bạn này Đấy mình rất thích
với anh nhá để mình giải thích từ Cái
câu lệnh một số bạn hiểu cái hàng này
thì đầu tiên là diện nó sẽ đến cao ít
của gì từ C2 đến C6 bạ từ 33 đến A9 đúng
không Tức là thiện Nếu như mà đang ở rơm
là cái ô C7 đúng không Thì nó sẽ đến từ
C2 đến C6 lại tức là nó sẽ đến trước đấy
nó đến những cái danh sách mà cái tên
trước đấy mà nó đã có rồi nhá trong cái
gì trong AOE 3 đã chí này đấy có những
cái gì về chọn phân tích một đây để cao
ít là 11 và nó sẽ đặt không đúng không
Thì cái không này chính là diện chính là
rơm thì nó mới không có con gà này có
rồi đúng không gà có rồi thì mà một kem
có người cũng mặc một tất cả là có rồi
chỉ còn phải ông Rơm này là chưa có đấy
thì nó sẽ trả về kết quả không Ở cuối
cùng ông Rơm ở đây đúng không Đây bây
giờ nó lại mát mát của không và không
Ừ thì nó sẽ ra kết quả là 7 này đúng
không nét của không trong cái cái cái ô
này còn thích rồi đấy thì nó sẽ ra là
cái quả bóng bẩy và cái hàm index của
bảy thì nó sẽ trả về rơm đúng không
Index của 7 Từ view a339 từ 33 đến 9 mà
lấy đến các phần tử thứ 7 từ a339 thì nó
chính là rơm ở đây chạm thích vào đây
Bây giờ mình sẽ lên cái phần khóc hay để
cho con xem nhé mình sẽ tích và mái tóc
này vào mình sẽ làm cái công thức này
cho bạn xem này đấy thì đầu tiên nó lại
đến diện nó lại đến từ cái phần trên cái
phần khóc này khác Này làm gì ạ từ cái
c40 cho nên nó sẽ đến từ C2 đến C3 thôi
đấy bạn thấy cho mình nhát Nếu mà không
thích ở C4 thì nó sẽ đến từ C2 C3 thôi
C2 là tới bắt đầu là nó cố định còn C3
Cái sau thì cái số bài nó không cố định
đúng không Thì cứ dịch lại thì nó sẽ đến
ngay trước nó đấy Họ sẽ thích ở đây này
Đấy thì nó sẽ ra là 10 ngay tại vì mới
có chỉ có cái xe lên đúng không Thì cái
ông thoát này là đang là không có đấy
thì ngay cái phần này là khô
ở Bạc mét của không ấy thì với cái Học
mát thì nó sẽ tìm cái vị trí không đầu
tiên thì không đầu tiên nó làm ở ngay vị
trí thứ hai này thì cắn nó sẽ trả về cái
giá trị thứ hai của cái hạt lép mà Đấy
nó sẽ trả lời cái là xuống hay và nó sẽ
gái luôn của Index từ a ba đến A9 mà nó
lấy cái thứ hai thì nó phải là thóc đúng
không có thích ở đây để nó sẽ ra tóc các
bạn về cơ ạ tìm hiểu thêm về cái công
thức này nha bây giờ kéo xuống này đây
thì từ sau cái rương là hết rồi đúng
không nó sẽ là lót Viber cho nên mình sẽ
xóa đi Đấy công thức của mình là như vậy
nhá thì tương tự cái ví dụ thứ 10 thì nó
cũng khá là phức tạp Yêu cầu là địa điểm
của bao học sinh cao nhất thì mình xác
định bao sinh cao nhất đúng không Đấy
thì mình sẽ dùng cái công thức mạng khá
là phức tạp này thì các bạn sẽ tìm hiểu
thêm nhé đấy Đây là bị yêu cầu để tìm
hiểu thêm cho các bạn nhá đến nâng cao
đấy Ok như vậy là xong cái bài học ngày
hôm nay bây giờ mình sẽ đi vào cái câu
hỏi nhé à
những câu hỏi về nhà của mình nhận diện
đây là mình có danh sách các nhân viên
đúng không Còn đây là doanh thu các cái
tháng của các nhân viên Bây giờ mình cần
tìm điện tìm với doanh thu nhỏ nhất
nhưng mà phải lớn hơn không Để doanh thu
nhỏ nhất Min nhỏ nhất nhưng mà địa phải
lớn không Tức là ô không thì mình không
tính đúng không Không thì có thể cái
tháng này bạn này bận cái việc gì đấy
thì bạn ấy không kinh doanh cái gì đấy
nhá Thì bây giờ mình sẽ tìm cái pin nhỏ
nhất mà để mà nó phải là lớn không yêu
cầu của bài tập về nhà là như vậy nhé Ok
như vậy là mình đã kết thúc bài học ngày
hôm nay ở đây cảm ơn các bạn đã theo dõi
các bạn nhớ đăng ký Kênh để cập nhật
video mới nhất của gà cũng như chia sẻ
để giúp mọi người của Ngọc Bích Trang
nhé Xin chào và hẹn gặp lại ở
ừ ừ